bayerns wir führen dieses gespräch um
20.15 ungefähr wie ist die bewertungen
der bisherigen wahlergebnisse
also es ist ein
unglaublicher erfolg für olaf scholz und
die gesamte spd
wir sind vor einem jahr vor zwei jahren
ungefähr angetreten als wir gesagt haben
wir wollen die große koalition ablösen
wir wollen eine regierung eine
regierungsmehrheit unter führung der spd
mit einem kanzler scholz das haben wir
vor einem jahr schon festgelegt und all
das ist möglich geworden also ich habe
im moment alles andere als irgendeine
also eine an eine beeinträchtigung eines
glücksgefühls heute abend möglich
geworden aber es ist noch nicht sicher
denn auch der konkurrent armin laschet
beansprucht eine nächste
regierungsbildung für sich das ist
eigentlich das eigentlich die
eigentliche nachricht würde ich mal
sagen weil und noch vor wenigen tagen
die csu klar gesagt hat wenn sie nicht
erster sind dann gehören sie die
opposition
das war eindeutig gerichtet gegen armin
laschet jetzt sieht man man kann die
macht vielleicht doch erhalten was immer
alles eigentlich elixir sozusagen für
die tätigkeit der konservativen im
parlament gewesen ist ich sage das
spricht für sich selbst eine partei die
über acht prozent abstürzt die meint
aber weil sie doch noch mit anderen
partnern reagieren regieren könnte dass
sie das durch bekommen halte ich für
jährlich wieder ziemlich inakzeptabel
aber das müssen dann auch andere
gesprächspartner entscheiden mit denen
diese mehrheit zustande kommen sie haben
viel politik erfahrungen sie haben auch
viel sondierungs erfahrung wie geht das
denn jetzt in den nächsten sagen wir mal
acht bis zehn bis 14 tagen weiter
ich glaube dass wir vielleicht mal eine
ganz kurze verschnaufpause leisten
können aber nicht lange weil dann muss
man mit anderen gespräche führen es geht
wie wir immer wissen darum dass jeder
natürlich viel von seinem programm
durchsetzen möchte und dass man suchen
muss gibt es dafür eine ausreichende
schnittmenge die auch jeder seinen
wählerinnen und wählern vermitteln kann
und das ist kein automatismus dann kann
man auch heute abend nicht lösen das
erfordert gespräche ich glaube aber dass
vernünftige menschen miteinander reden
können müssen aber wie sieht es konkret
aus gibt es schon überlegungen wer wann
mit wem in welcher reihenfolge redet bzw
ob olaf scholz beziehungsweise sie und
ihre co parteivorsitzende saskia esken
beispielsweise auf die grünen und auf
die fdp zugehen oder wie wird das
aussehen also erstmal bleiben wir so
geschlossen beieinander wie wir das vor
der wahl auch waren und jetzt schon so
auch zu zeiten als wir noch nicht auf
einen solchen erfolg zugesteuert sind
und das gilt natürlich auch für solche
gespräche die werden zwischen parteien
geführt insofern ist das klar dass es
die vorsitzenden und der kanzel
kanzlerkandidat machen werden sicher
auch nicht alleine das kann man sich
auch vorstellen natürlich machen wir uns
überlegungen haben überlegungen im
vorfeld gemacht aber das war jetzt auf
der grundlage des letztendlich
feststehenden ergebnisses und ich sag
jetzt mal auch wirklich einen moment
lang sacken lassen es dann wirklich
entscheiden und nicht über die medien
jetzt angenehm